Die Webseite Archive Org hat über 2000 Spieleklassiker für die antike Plattform DOS freigegeben. Sie lassen sich direkt im Browser spielen, einige können sogar heruntergeladen werden. Unter den Spielen befinden sich Evergreens, wie Wolfenstein Deidre, Lemmings und Prince of Persia. Archive Org ist bekannt durch das seit 1996 gepflegte Archiv von digitalen Kulturgütern, darunter einer regelmäßigen Kopie des gesamten World Wide Web. Wer ab morgen weiter Facebook nutzt, muss sich künftig mehr Werbung gefallen lassen. Das soziale Netzwerk führt gegen den Widerstand von Politik und Datenschützern seine neuen AGB ein. Damit ist es Facebook erlaubt, auch alle Aktivitäten im restlichen Internet auszuwerten und passende Werbung zu platzieren. Ein Widerspruch gegen die neuen AGB ist nicht möglich. Die einzige Alternative besteht im Löschen des eigenen Profils. Mit einem sogenannten Super Cookie verfolgt der US-Internet-Anbieter Verizon seinen Nutzer im Netz. Dazu injiziert er eigene personalisierte Marker in den Datenverkehr seiner Kunden, mit denen diese von Werbeanbietern wiedererkannt werden können. Zu den Nutzern dieses Tracking-Verfahrens zählen unter anderem Google, Facebook, Twitter und Yahoo. Wehren können sich die Nutzer nur dann, wenn die besuchten Webseiten verschlüsselt per HTTPS erreichbar sind.
Die Nerd-News des Chaos Computer Clubs im Chaosradio in Blumenau, Fritz, präsentiert von Martin Schneider. Herzlich willkommen zurück im Chaos Radio im Blue Moon auf Fritz. Heute zusammen mit Starbucks, Danimo und Erdgeist. Alles sehr seriöse Leute vom Chaos Computer Club, die wie immer im...
Tänzt du mich grad seriös?
Das ist geheim. Was wollte ich sagen? Ich wollte sagen, dass wir jeden letzten Donnerstag in ungeraden Monaten ja hier das Chaos Radio machen. Das heißt eben vom Chaos Computer Club kommen Leute vorbei und erklären irgendwas, was mit Computerkram zu tun hat im weitesten Sinne. Und heute wollen sie mal einen Blick geben in die Großveranstaltungen, die sie selber machen. Und das finde ich wirklich das Bezaubernde quasi daran. Es gab also diesen Chaos Communication Congress. Zehntausend Besucher waren da bei der letzten Ausgabe und der ist halt selbst organisiert. Also von Freiwilligen, die da wirklich richtig viel Zeit reinbuttern. Und trotzdem funktioniert das irgendwie. Wir haben schon gelernt, dass das, wie gesagt, das ist alle Freiwillige sind, die sogar noch selber den Eintritt zahlen. Wie man so ein Gebäude organisiert, was man mit den Vorträgen macht, wo man die herbekommt und was Engel sind, nämlich die kleine Helferlein und wie man die so managt und was ein POC ist, nämlich ein eigenes Telefonsystem auf dem Chaos Communication Congress und wollen gleich noch lernen, was ein NOC und ein VOC ist. Vorher nochmal den Anruf aufzurufen, ne umgedreht den Aufruf anzurufen, falls ihr selber Fragen zum Chaos Communication Congress habt oder euch nicht traut zu fragen, dann ruft trotzdem an 0371 77 97 21 20. Oder wenn ihr selber schon mal da wart und eine Geschichte zu erzählen habt, könnt ihr auch gerne hier anrufen. 0331 77 97 110. So, nachdem wir vorhin schon gelernt haben, was ein POC ist, er hat es gar nicht erklärt, aber ich glaube, es heißt Phone Operations Center wahrscheinlich, lernen wir jetzt, was ein NOC ist, und zwar von Leon. Hallo und guten Abend. Was ist denn ein NOC?
Ein NOC ist ein Network Operations Center und das macht nichts anderes als Internet.
Warte, Moment mal.
Nur Internet.
Aber Internet gibt es doch mittlerweile überall. Warum braucht man besonderes Internet auf einer Großveranstaltung mit 10.000 Leuten?
Ja, wir wollen das halt selber machen, wie wir alles selber machen wollen, weil das Internet in den Größenordnungen, die wir jetzt haben wollen, gibt es halt nicht einfach so eine Versteckdose.
Was heißt denn Größenordnung?
Na, wir bauen da so Internet mit, ich glaube, einer Bandweite von 50 Gigabit pro Sekunde, hatten wir dieses Jahr. Das ist einfach mal viel größer als alles, was man so kaufen kann am Markt.
Marcus, was sagst du so?
Ich wollte gerade sagen, also 50 Gigabit, das sind ja 50.000 Megabit pro Sekunde. Und ich habe zu Hause 50 Megabit pro Sekunde, was die Hälfte von dem ist, was man am Markt so kriegt. Also 100 MBit ist gerade so ein Anschluss, den man gerade handelsüblich noch für zu Hause kaufen kann.
Ja, symmetrisch.
Genau, und du kannst genauso schnell hoch wie runterladen, was ja bei handelsüblichen Anschluss ist.
Ihr wolltet Leon nicht damit selber angeben lassen, oder? So dann Leon, die erste Frage, wo kriegt man denn so viel Internet am Stück überhaupt her?
Na ja, das kommt halt auch aus der Wand. Aber hinter der Dose in der Wand steckt da halt eine Glasfaser, die wir da hinlegen lassen haben. Also im Prinzip ein Kabel in einem Rechenzentrum. Und da haben wir dann ein eigener Hart verstehen. Und dann haben wir dort Verbindungen zu größeren Internet-Providern, die freundlich sind und uns da verschiedene Internet-Anschlüsse zur Verfügung stellen. Und aus den mehreren Anschlüssen bauen wir uns dann halt unser Internet auf dem Kongress zusammen.
Jetzt ist ja die größte Herausforderung, also habe ich als Besucher von Großveranstaltungen, immer die ein WLAN zu bauen, das funktioniert. Und tatsächlich hat auch der Kongress für mich, ich war glaube ich beim Vorletzten, also dieses Jahr war es extrem gut, aber davor war es immer sozusagen sehr brüchig, sage ich mal. Was ist denn die Schwierigkeit daran, ein großes WLAN zu bauen?
Ja, das wird sehr technisch.
Kannst du das auch einfach erklären?
Versuchen nicht technisch zu machen, genau. Das Problem ist halt, dass man funkt da auf einer gewissen Frequenz und auf der Frequenz kann aber immer nur einer gleichzeitig funken. Und wenn wir jetzt ganz viele Leute auf ganz wenig Raum haben, dann müssen die sich im Prinzip die Zeit, in der sie funken können, teilen. Das heißt, die Geschwindigkeit geht für alle runter, wenn es viele sind. Das heißt, was man dann tun muss, ist verschiedene Frequenzen nehmen, aber davon gibt es nicht so viele. Und das heißt, was man dann tun muss, ist einfach verschiedene Exis-Points zu wenden. Also im Prinzip ganz viele Antennen, die immer nur mit ganz wenig Sendeleistung funken, sodass man an verschiedenen Stellen wieder die gleichen Frequenzen nehmen kann, ohne dass sie sich stören. Also im Prinzip solche Sachen muss man dann versuchen, mit Hardware zu erschlagen, indem man da mehr Geräte verwendet. Und am Ende kommt man dann halt auch an physikalische Limits. Das kommt dann auch darauf an, wie gut die Hardware, die man dann dieses Jahr zur Verfügung hat, damit umgehen kann. Weil manche Hersteller machen dann auch gewisse Tricks, um ein bisschen das Rauschen gering zu halten und andere Sachen.
Wo kommt denn die Hardware her? Also nicht nur die WLAN-Hardware, sondern die allgemeine Hardware.
Genau, es gibt einen kleinen Teil, den wir selber haben. Einen anderen kleinen Teil mieten wir. Aber man kann halt nicht alles mieten. Das ist genau wie mit dem Internet, das kann man sich auch nicht kaufen, wenn man den größten Organis haben will. Und da haben wir einfach in der Vergangenheit immer Glück gehabt, dass sich Firmen gefunden haben, die uns sowas halt zur Verfügung stellen. Gegen relativ wenig Gegenleistungen. Also hat Starbuck vorhin schon gesagt, die kriegen eigentlich nichts weiter als irgendwie dann mal ein Logo als Dankeschön auf so eine Seite im Biggie gestellt. Ja, aber da haben wir immer relativ viel Glück, dass wir da an Firmen rankommen, die uns einfach mal so einen Stapel von Routern liefern oder WLAN-Access Points.
Kannst du mal eine Größenordnung sagen, so vom Preislichen her, was wir da so zu stehen haben?
Also von einem Routerhersteller haben wir Hardware im Wert von ungefähr 3 Millionen versichert.
Und das sind nur die Router gewesen?
Ja, ein Großteil der Kernnetzwerke hatte, ja. Das war schon das teure Zeug. Die WLAN-Hardware ist auch noch relativ teuer, da geht keine Größenordnung im Kopf. Die kamen auch von verschiedenen, ein Teil kam vom Hersteller und dann hatten wir noch einfach einen Nerd, der hat auch noch einen Stapel davon rumliegen. Ja, so sammelt man sich das halt zusammen.
Jetzt kann ich mir vorstellen, dass das eine Problem, um ein komplettes Netzwerk aufzubauen, ist tatsächlich die Technik. Das andere Problem, würde ich vermuten, was bei Computer immer so ist, ist das Ding, was da vorsitzt, nämlich der Mensch. Da kann ich mir zwei Arten von Problemen vorstellen. Das eine ist, man hat einfach technische Probleme, weil man mit irgendwas nicht klarkommt. Wie viel Zeit verbringt ihr mit Support-Anfragen? So, mein WLAN funktioniert nicht, hilf mir bitte.
Damit verbringe ich relativ wenig Zeit, denn dafür haben wir einen Helpdesk, und das wird von den Engeln betrieben. Gut gesourced. Die machen da ganz großartige Arbeit und fangen das alles für uns ab, sonst würden wir nämlich zu gar nichts mehr kommen. Dann hätten wir gar keine Zeit, das Internet zu bauen.
Die andere Frage, die ich mir stelle, ist, es ist ja generell so, dass Hacker ein Interesse daran haben, Dinge zu, das schöne Wort, was ich hier gelernt habe, zerforschen, also mal nachzugucken, inwieweit in so eine Infrastruktur technischer Natur, wie man da reinkommt, was man alles aufmachen kann usw. Habt ihr damit ein Problem, oder gibt es da so eine Art Nicht-Angriffspakt, weil es ist ja die Struktur für den Chaos-Congress?
Nein, also das Not besteht ja zum größten Teil aus sehr professionellen Leuten, die sowas taktiklich machen. Die haben eine gewisse Erfahrung und wissen, wie man Netzwerke absichert, dass man nicht die eigene Hardware in Griffen bekommt. Das geht schon.
Und wenn das passiert, dann weißt du, wo ihr sie findet?
Wir hatten dieses Jahr auf einen Fall, da haben wir an einer Stelle vergessen, was abzusichern, da irgendwelche Limits zu setzen. Und es ist uns natürlich prompt auf die Füße gefallen, weil ich glaube, das war noch ein Tag, bevor der Congress anfing. Nee, das war entweder der erste Tag, oder der davor. Da hat tatsächlich jemand einfach einen stupiden Angriff gefahren, der einfach dadurch abgefangen wäre, wenn wir in so einer Konfig ein Limit eingetragen hätten, wie das auch normal gewesen wäre, das haben wir einfach vergessen. Und dann waren die Server kurz offline.
Und wie ist das mit, was ich mir auch vorstellen kann, da gibt ja dieses riesige Netzwerk, und das hat eine Anbindung nach draußen. Und da sind 10.000 Leute auf einem Platz, nicht wenige davon Leute, die Interesse an Computersicherheit und Zerforschen haben. Wer kommuniziert eigentlich sozusagen mit der Außenwelt, wenn da irgendwas kaputt geht und festgestellt wird, Moment mal, da gibt es diesen riesigen Internetknotenpunkt aus Hamburg.
Du meinst, wenn sich Leute beschweren, dass jemand ihr System kaputt gemacht hat, dann haben wir so eine Telefonnummer und da rufen dann die Leute ganz böse manchmal an. Also manche sind weniger böse, manche sind mehr böse. Aber wir können halt meistens auch nichts tun, denn wir wissen nicht, wer die User sind. Wir können nicht sagen, wenn der eine RP draus hat, das war der und der User, weil wir die Information selber nicht speichern. Wir versuchen ja auch auf Datensparsenkrankheit zu achten und speichern nur das, was wir wirklich speichern müssen. Und können da meistens auch nichts tun.
Na gut, aber was ihr schon teilweise macht, ist tatsächlich dann den Netzbereich zu blockieren. Also einfach zu sagen, aus dem Kongressenetz wird halt nicht mehr auf diesen Netzbereich zugegriffen.
Genau, das ist halt alles, was wir tun können. Wenn jemand ein Problem hat, dann können wir dafür sorgen, dass er von uns nie wieder Daten bekommt.
Stimmt das, dass das Leute auch präventiv anfragen im Vorfeld?
Ja, das gibt so ein, zwei Fälle. Die kennen uns halt schon und die bitten dann einfach, dass sie auch dieses Jahr wieder geblockt werden.
Und das macht ihr dann auch?
Das erspart dann halt vielen Seiten Ärger.
Okay, die letzte Frage, die ich zu einem Netzwerk auf dem Kongressenetz noch hätte, ist zu sagen, wie muss man sich da als einzelner, also als User verhalten, kann ich dann einfach sagen, problemlos ins WLAN gehen und denken so, ihr passt schon auf mich auf, dass mir nichts passiert oder muss man da besondere Vorkehrungen treffen?
Ne, du bist da am echten Internet. Mit allen Seinen gefahren, also da ist halt keine Firewall davor. Man sollte halt schon dafür sorgen, dass sein Rechner die aktuelle Software hat, dass da keine steinalte Software mit Sicherheitsproblemen draufläuft. Dann wäre es sinnvoll, also einfach gute Praxen anzuwenden.
Keine unnötigen Dienste laufen lassen, die nach außen offen sind.
Genau, keine unnötigen Dienste laufen lassen. Möglichst nicht seine wichtigsten Daten drauf haben. Also gut, dann so ein Rechner kann ja auch mal geklaut werden, ganz plump. Aber falls doch was passiert, dann ist das halt nicht so schlimm. Und solche Sachen. Ja, man soll sowieso immer das Verschlüsseln. Wir bieten jetzt auch ein verschlüsseltes WLAN in jüngerer Zeit. Aber das offene gibt es immer noch. Weil wir einfach gerne zeigen, ja, so ist, so ein sicheres Internet. Kümmert euch um Verschlüsselung. Und es ist halt immer noch ein Hackeyevent. Da kann halt schon was passieren.
Wie viel Zeit steckt ihr da rein?
Äh, in das Internet.
Genau, also sozusagen in diesem Betrieb des NOX. Inklusive, also sagen das ganze Jahr über. Insgesamt, nicht nur auf dem Kongress, sondern insgesamt an Zeit.
Naja, wir haben im Oktober angefangen, zu überlegen, wer macht es dieses Jahr und wer ist dabei. Und dann wird es halt, im Oktober ist noch nicht so viel los, aber im Dezember ist das schon so ein Halbtagsjob mindestens. Und dann waren wir eine Woche vorher, auf jeden Fall. Eine Woche vor dem Kongress vor Ort und haben da raufgebaut.
Letzte Frage an dich wirklich, wenn man da irgendwie 30.000 Kilometer Netzwerkkabel verlegt, wie viel vergisst man davon, wie viel fehlt nachher?
Gute Frage. Weiß ich gar nicht so genau. Es wird immer ein bisschen schwunter, aber das ist jetzt nicht problematisch, weil ich hab jetzt keine genaue Inventur, wie viel Netzwerkkabel wir noch haben. Das ist auch ein Problem, weil wir jedes Mal überlegen müssen, wie viel wir nachkaufen. Wir nehmen uns immer vor, unter dem Jahr mal eine Inventur zu machen.
Bis jetzt ist noch genug Kabel da. Leon Wallers, der erklärt, was das NOC, also das Network Operations Center, auf einer Hacker-Großveranstaltung macht. Jetzt wissen wir, dass man Telefone betreiben kann, dass man Vorträge machen kann, dass man Netzwerk betreiben kann. Wir wissen jetzt insbesondere, was ein POC und ein NOC ist. Wir lernen jetzt, was ein VOC ist, und zwar von Dani Mode, der hier im Studio ist.
Ein VOC ist ein Video Operations Center. Du möchtest wissen, was das ist, nicht was es heißt. Na klar, wir haben jetzt schon diskutiert, es gibt Vorträge und es gibt ein sehr großes Kongresscenter. Aber es gibt immer mal wieder Umstände. Es gibt ja so Leute, die zwischen den Jahren durchaus irgendwelche Verpflichtungen haben oder so, die halt, jetzt guckt nicht so verständnislos, es gibt es. Und diese Leute möchten halt vielleicht auch gerne diese Vorträge entweder im Stream oder wie man auf Neudeutsch so schön sagt, zeitsoverän sehen können. Also quasi dann, wenn sie Zeit haben. Und das dafür sorgen, also quasi wir vom VOG. Das heißt, wir haben dort in den Sälen Kameras stehen. Wir haben Videoregie. Wir haben Engel, die diese Kameras bedienen, die quasi die Sachen zuliefern. Und wir bedienen halt auch den ganzen Rest der Kette. Das heißt, die Videos müssen irgendwie ins Internet kommen, im Internet verteilt werden. Das Ganze muss mit irgendwie auch mindestens irgendwie, ich glaube, im Peak hatten wir mal so 9000 Zuschauer gleichzeitig.
Das sind weniger als Besucher im Haus.
Und das muss halt alles bespielt werden. Und wir haben da quasi eine Truppe zusammengetrommelt, die all das macht. Also quasi vom Saal, vom Aufnehmen bis hinzu, endet hinter dir bei dir im Browser oder im Videoplayer, wird quasi die gesamte Kette abgefackelt. Weil es geht.
Naja, und weil da laufen vier Vorträge immer gleichzeitig. Das heißt, die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass man das immer gucken kann, was man sich anschauen möchte, ist zumindest nicht für die ganze Veranstaltung gegeben. Und da ist es schon schön, wenn man dann auch später noch nachschauen kann, was man verpasst hat.
Und tatsächlich, die meisten Leute kommen auch wirklich halt inzwischen zum Kongress nicht wegen der Vorträge, sondern um halt Leute zu treffen. Aber man will halt trotzdem schon gern wissen, was so neu ist, der der Kund getan wurde. Das heißt, man sitzt dann halt die ersten zwei, drei Wochen nach dem Kongress und guckt sich halt Kongress wie vor dem Wahn.
Ich nehme das immer vor, es klappt nie. Aber dann würde ich sagen, die einfache Lösung ist, wir stellen eine Kamera dahin und dann stecken wir das dann in den Computer ein und dann streamt das irgendwie ins Internet. Das ist dann die einfache Lösung. Ich vermute mal, ihr habt etwas anderes aufgebaut. Also wie viel Technik steckt da bei euch drin?
Extrem viel. Also wir haben die letzten Kongresse, eigentlich müssen wir mal überhaupt so anfangen. Das Ganze ist erstmal nicht auf dem Mist des CCC selber gewachsen, sondern wir hatten immer Hilfe von der FEMM. Das sind die Forschungsgemeinschaft Elektronische Medien der TU Ilmenau. Und die haben das quasi eine ganz lange Zeit gemacht, bis wir dann irgendwann gesagt haben, wir möchten das auch machen. Da hat die FEMM nicht gesagt, boah, ihr seid blöd, macht das doch selber und geht weg. Sondern die machen das mit uns zusammen. Und dieses Jahr war es sogar noch toller. Da hat uns sogar die Arbeitsgemeinschaft für Studie- und Senderfragen der TU Braunschweig mitgeholfen. Das heißt, wir haben das quasi im Dreierverbund gemacht. Und wie man sich das vorstellen kann, so uninahe Veranstaltungen, die haben natürlich irgendwie auch richtig Hardware da stehen. Und wir hatten eigentlich auch übrigens alles als Open Source zu haben, auch unsere Erweiterungen. Haben wir eigentlich immer versucht, darauf zu achten, dass wir jetzt nicht Spezial-Hardware anschaffen, sondern dass wir das mit allgemein Technik machen können. Haben also dann so Boxen uns herstellen lassen, so Flight Cases, wo dann handelsübliche Computer, eine gute Kamera und so etwas drin ist und einen Haufen Kabel. Und damit konnten wir das abfackeln. Dieses Jahr wollten wir es unbedingt in HD produzieren. Und da haben wir dann leider die nicht mehr rechtzeitig alles an Start bekommen. Da ist uns dann dankenswerterweise von diesen beiden Gemeinschaften und von Einzelpersonen, die absurd viel Hardware teilweise im Keller rumstehen haben, ausgeholfen worden.
Das ist dann der Vorteil, wenn man viele Nerds kennt.
Genau.
Bei euch nochmal die Frage jetzt, also beim Phone Operations Center und Network kann ich mir vorstellen, da will man eh nur hin, wenn man eh schon viel Ahnung oder sich für die Materie interessiert. Jetzt kann ich mir vorstellen, so Kamerakind würde man gerne auch mal so machen, dass man denkt so, hey, ich finde das irgendwie cool, ich würde dir gerne helfen. Ist das sozusagen so eine eingeschworene Gesellschaft? Oder kann man auch sagen, hier Leute, ich würde auch gerne was machen, kann ich damit machen?
Na, das sind im Prinzip wieder so Kamerakind kannst du jederzeit machen. Du gehst in unser Engelsystem und sagst, ich möchte für diesen Talk Kamerakind machen. Und wenn dann noch niemand anderes Kamerakind ist, bist du Kamerakind. Und wenn du gerne irgendwie Regie führen möchtest, dann klickst du auf, ich möchte gerne die Regie Schicht übernehmen, dann bist du Regie. Du kriegst natürlich von uns Einführungen und wir finden das natürlich total toll, wenn du dich so ein bisschen mit dem Thema schon auskennst. Weil das ist immer so ein bisschen das Problem, die Leute, die Regie führen, die halten sich dann alle für Roland Emmerich und die die Kamera führen, die hoffen dann auch irgendwie auf einen Oscar. Während meistens irgendwie das Gebot der Stunde ist, irgendwie stille Bilder einzufangen, sodass man wirklich das nachvollziehen kann. Und mit viel Technik kommt natürlich auch viel Spielerei. Und quasi so ein bisschen diesen Impuls, jetzt unbedingt überall schalten zu wollen. Wenn man den einmal unter Kontrolle hat und irgendwie weiß, was man tut, weil es ist ja auch wahnsinnig viele Knöpfe, wir versuchen immer so viel wie möglich abzutapen, aber da bleiben immer noch genug Knöpfe übrig. Und wenn man das einmal unter Kontrolle hat, dann funktioniert das auch sehr gut. Und wir haben dann also auch mit den etwas erfahrenen sehr gute Erfahrungen gemacht. Was nicht heißt, dass wir niemanden Neues mehr nehmen. Wir versuchen auch kontinuierlich quasi die Schulung, die da im Vorfeld passieren. Wir haben da halt nur einen Tag Zeit. Da versuchen wir halt so ein bisschen Schulung zu leisten. Geht halt nur in beschränkter Maß, aber das versuchen wir halt zu verbessern.
Okay, also man lernt auch sagen, nicht alle Jobs sind glamourös. Manchmal geht es auch einfach um Stillhalten. Und im Gegensatz zu sagen, zum Türjob kann man sich dann glaube ich nicht mal mit dem Nachbarn unterhalten, wenn gerade der Talk läuft.
Doch, wir haben natürlich Intercom mit den Kameraleuten.
Hey, der Job ist zwar nicht langweilig, aber wir haben technisches Spielzeug. Sehr schön, wunderbar. So, dann wissen wir jetzt, was ein POC, NOC und VOC ist. Dann fehlt uns eigentlich nur noch die vierbuchstabliche Abkürzung, nämlich Zert.
Die hat uns übrigens dieses Jahr sehr geholfen.
Das kann sie gleich bestens selber erzählen, in Gestalt von Madoc. Hallo, guten Tag. Was ist denn ein Zert?
Das Zert steht als Abkürzung für Chaos Emergency Response Team und ist so der Rettungsengel.
Jetzt Rettungsengel, wenn mir die Mate umgefallen ist oder tatsächlich im medizinischen Sinne?
Also du wirst es dich wundern. Tatsächlich werden wir auch gerufen für Fälle aus der Klasse. Mate ist umgefallen, also so vom Scheregrad tatsächlich. Es geht tatsächlich darum, dass wir zuschauen, wenn es Leuten schlecht geht oder wenn Leute einfach Hilfe brauchen, medizinische Hilfe, die von weiter her kommen, sich im Bereich Hamburg nicht so auskennen, sich an uns wenden und bei uns entweder direkt Hilfe bekommen oder auf jeden Fall dann direkt weitergeleitet werden können, dass wir ohne selber irgendwo stecken zu bleiben, an Stellen weitergeleitet werden, wo sie Hilfe bekommen können.
Aber seid ihr sozusagen alles irgendwie ausgebildete Ersteil von Sanität oder was? Oder seid einfach nur Leute, die sich die Zeit nehmen, um Menschen, die sich in den Fingern geschnitten haben, an die Hand zu nehmen und zu pusten?
Das ist völlig bunt. Also wir haben alle Qualifikationsstufen da. Wir haben Ärzte da, wir haben aber auch Rettungsassistenten, Rettungssanitäter, aber bis auf Leute, die, ich sag mal, zu damals Führerscheinzeiten den Kurs hier Lebensrettung-Sofortmaßnahmen gemacht haben. Aber auch die setzen wir ein. Von den Qualifikationen ist alles bunt da. Und was es so schön macht, ist, dass es ein unheimlich buntes Bild ist. Wir haben Leute, die Wasserrettung bei der DLRG als Hobby machen. Wir haben Leute, die fürs DRK hauptamtlich fahren. Leute, die hin und wieder auf Sanitätsdiensten dabei sind. Wir haben Leute, die als Krankenschwester im Kongo gearbeitet haben. Höhenretter hatten wir dieses Jahr, ganz großartig. Wir waren wirklich auf alles vorbereitet.
Wie viel seid ihr denn so ungefähr?
Also Hilfeangeboten hatten über 100 Menschen. Wir hatten über 100 Leute, die zu uns gekommen sind, und gesagt haben, ich hätte Lust, für euch zu engeln. Da wir dieses Jahr aber jetzt wirklich mal etwas härtere Maßstäbe angelegt haben, ist das dann super, aber wir brauchen Ausbildungsnachweis. Wir brauchen wirklich jetzt den Nachweis deiner Qualifikation, dass du das, was du sagst, also Rettungssanitär oder Rettungsassistent, gemacht hast, dass du das uns einmal zumindest nachweisen kannst, bevor wir dich auf den Patienten auch in dieser Qualifikation loslassen. Und so sind aber immerhin am Ende noch knapp über 70 Helfer übrig geblieben, die fest bei uns eingebucht waren im System als Helfer.
70?
Ja, das sieht immer, man sieht, wir versuchen immer so ein bisschen unterm Radar zu laufen. Man sieht hin und wieder mal so ein paar Zertengel so durch die Menge schleichen, irgendwo im Hintergrund ein bisschen Überblick bewahren.
Aber schon in so einem Westen auch.
Genau, also erkennbar sind wir schon, der eine mehr, der andere weniger. Also einer war dieses Jahr auf jeden Fall sehr klar erkennbar mit dem lauten Ausruf Bidu, Bidu, Bidu. Ich glaube, hier ist noch viel in der Inne oben geblieben. Aber hinter den Kulissen ist es halt mehr. Zu Spitzenzeiten haben wir 15 Leute gleichzeitig im Einsatz etwa. Zur Nerd-Nachtzeit, also nicht das, was jetzt die meisten Leute als Nachtzeit betrachten. Aber wenn halt wenig los ist, dann reduzieren wir auf sechs. Aber das sind halt auch wirklich so viele Leute, die gleichzeitig immer da sind.
Jetzt, ich traue mich nicht zu fragen, aber was sind denn so Fälle, zu denen ihr gerufen werdet? Also jetzt die schlimmsten?
Der absolute Klassiker ist natürlich, habt da mal eine Kopfschmerz-Tablette. Und ich habe mich geschnitten und das Eis von den Cocktails ist so scharf. Und irgendwas ist mir ins Auge gekommen. Aber wir hatten tatsächlich auch Leute in den Jahren, in denen ich dabei war, denen es auch richtig, richtig dreckig ging. Und darum finde ich das Zert so wertvoll, weil es wirklich jetzt den Leuten, die sonst, wenn sie sich so an den Rettungsdienst oder an den normalen öffentlichen medizinischen Hilfsdienst wenden müssten, die werden einfach weg, also so für Stunden, wenn man sich mal an eine Notaufnahme eines großstädtischen Krankenhauses gewandt hat, da man ja manchmal sechs Stunden die profanen Architektur genossen, bevor man überhaupt mal einen Arztkontakt hatte. Und da können wir halt schauen, was wir so aus eigenem Bild sehr viel schneller machen können. Und es sind etwa 250 Leute, nein es sind auf dem Punkt genau 250 Leute, die jetzt am 31 C3 bei uns behandelt wurden, regelrecht behandelt. Das klingt auch erstmal nicht so viel, aber es waren auch schon einige dabei, die wir durchaus über mehrere Stunden, sechs, acht, zehn Stunden bei uns durchgehend behandelt haben.
Was war denn da los?
Unterschiedlich, es gibt welche, die überschätzen sich einfach. Das ist natürlich jetzt ein Event, auf das man sich ein ganzes Jahr freut, und dann gibt man eine Mate nach der anderen, weil man muss wirklich alles mitbekommen, und dann vergisst man aber noch irgendwie was zu essen, und dann gibt man einfach weg.
Das ist das, was ich vorhin meinte, mit dem Engel, der drei Tage nicht geschlafen hat.
Ja, nicht nur Engel, es sind Congress-Teilnehmer. Gerade Leute, die das erste Mal da so alles erzählt bekommen haben, laufen ja rum, wie Alice im Wunderband auf dem Weg durch den Kaminchenbau. Das verschätzt man sich manchmal halt ein bisschen. Und dann gibt es sehr unterschiedlich dieses Jahr immer so ein bisschen mehr Magen-Darm-Infektionskrankheiten. Ich glaube, vorhin hat es jemand erwähnt, Hände war schon mal total auf den Wogen dieses Jahr. Hat sich durchgesetzt, ist auch mal schön, dass so Klassiker auf dem Kongress sich durchsetzen.
Ja, das Wok hat es dann auf die harte Tour gelernt.
Ja, ich meine, das macht es immer so anders. Bei uns waren halt die Witze, wir haben immer so ein bisschen aus Pock geblinzelt, also so in Anerkennung an Douglas Adams. Ich kenne ja die Rasse, die ausgelöscht wurde, weil die Telefonhörer nicht mehr abgewischt wurden. Aber das ist halt das, was es so schön macht, das ist das Nördige. Also anders als andere medizinische Mahandungseinrichtungen.
Ich muss auch sagen, ich war schwerstens begeistert vom CIRT. Also wie sie mit dieser Situation, die aus unserer Sicht schon ins Kritische gegangen ist, wirklich so souverän umgegangen ist, die Ruhe behalten hat, gesagt hat, bleibt mal ruhig, wir kümmern uns drum, wir sagen euch, sobald es so aussieht, als wenn es problematisch werden würde. Also aus Orga-Sicht war es wirklich wie eine Top-Leistung gewesen.
Es gibt tatsächlich das geflügelte Wort von der Kongressseuche. Das ist halt meistens eine Grippe oder so, was hier rumgeht. Aber dieses Mal war es etwas mit Magendarm. Wir müssen gleich Nachrichten machen. Ich habe noch eine letzte Frage an dich. Bei allen anderen Sachen kann ich mir vorstellen, ich möchte das gerne machen, weil ich möchte mit der Technik rumspielen. Diese Faszination erschließt sich mir beim Medikamententeil oder beim Medizinenteil eher nicht. Warum will man das machen?
Das ist unglaublich schwer zu beantworten, die Frage. Das Neue zu entdecken ist für viele nicht so gegeben, weil die meisten gelernt haben, wie das Reboot eines biologischen Systems funktioniert. Ich glaube, es ist wirklich die Arbeitsweise in dem Bereich, also medizinischer Bereich Arbeitsweise, kennt irgendwo jeder, aber es ist hier völlig anders. Also ich arbeite hier neben Menschen und mit Menschen, die so bunt in ihrer Zusammensetzung sind und so völlig anders, jeder für sich, aber trotzdem ist man da in einer Gemeinsamkeit. Das habe ich tatsächlich noch nie irgendwo so erlebt. Und das ist ein unglaublich krasses Erlebnis. Also wir hatten 15-Jährige, die in wirklich verantwortungsvollen Positionen saßen, aber auch super performt haben. Wir hatten ältere Menschen dort, die ihre Sache gestanden haben. Es hat keiner hingeguckt, wer du bist, woher du kommst, aber die gemeinsame Arbeit hat uns verbunden. Und das ist ein Gefühl, das habe ich selten in dem Ausmaß erlebt. Das war großartig.
Und das wird auch noch anderen Menschen geholfen. Das hört sich wirklich sehr gut an. Ein Überblick über das Third hat uns MEDoc gegeben. So, jetzt wissen wir schon ziemlich viel über den Chaos Communication Congress und wie man so eine Großveranstaltung organisiert und produziert. Wir machen gleich noch weiter. Vor allem die Nachrichten mit Wetter und Verkehr. Jetzt aber los.
Na toll, gerade wollten wir euch sagen, dass einer der großartigsten Berliner Livebands in einer der schönsten Berliner Open Air Locations und das auch noch in einer der besten Berliner Jahreszeiten spielt. Und dann war das Konzert schon ausverkauft. Damit uns das beim Zusatzkonzert nicht noch mal passiert, lassen wir das gequatsche und starten gleich mit. Fritz präsentiert The Beat Stakes, das Zusatzkonzert.
Freitag, 3. Juli.
The Beat Stakes, live in der Wohleide. Präsentiert von Fritz.
Fritz Nachrichten.
Mit Martin Schneider.
Die neue griechische Regierung will keine einseitigen Schritte bei der Überwindung der Schuldenkrise. Das sagte EU-Parlamentspräsident Schulz nach einem Treffen mit dem neuen Ministerpräsidenten Tsipras. Demnach wolle die Regierung in Athen Lösungen auf gemeinsamer Grundlage suchen. Begrüßenswert sei, dass die Steuerhinterziehung und die Korruption im Land bekämpft werden solle. Tsipras erklärte nach dem Gespräch, Athen wünsche eine Schuldenkonferenz. Dazu werde seine Regierung Vorschläge machen, die mit den Partnern in der Eurozone besprochen werden sollten. Um die grenzüberschreitende Kriminalität besser zu bekämpfen, hat der Bundestag heute dem deutsch-polnischen Polizeiabkommen zugestimmt. Dadurch können Polizisten im jeweiligen Nachbarland Verdächtige überprüfen und festnehmen. Außerdem sollen deutsch-polnische Teams auf Streife gehen. Um Polizeihubschrauber müssen bei der Verfolgung von Flüchtenden nicht mehr an der Grenze umkehren. In die ehemalige Lausitz-Kaserne in Doberluck-Kirchheim sollen im kommenden Herbst die ersten 400 Flüchtlinge einziehen. Bis dahin seien die Gebäude hergerichtet, sagte Brandenburgs Innenminister Schulter am Abend bei einer Einwohnerversammlung. Dabei verteiligte er die Entscheidung für den Standort, der aufgrund des baulichen Zustandes die besten Voraussetzungen biete. Die ehemalige Kaserne soll eine Art Zweigstelle für die überfüllte Erstaufnahmestelle in Eisenhüttenstadt werden. Insgesamt sollen 800 Flüchtlinge untergebracht werden. Alba Berlin hat in der Basketball EuroLeague die dritte Niederlage kassiert. Bei Rotterstan Belgrad verlor der deutsche Vizemeister mit 69 zu 86. Für den serbischen Vizemeister war es der erste Sieg in der EuroLeague. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen in Berlin Köpenick haben wir 0 Grad, in Spandau 2, Lübbenau 2 Grad, Potsdam und Falkensee 1 Grad und Angermünde 0 Grad. Bis auf Minus 1 Grad geht es heute Nacht runter. Dazu gibt es Regen oder Schneeschauer. Vorsicht auf den Straßen, die können ordentlich glatt werden. Morgen gibt es erst mal Regen, am Vormittag zumindest. Am Nachmittag soll es dann meist trocken sein. Das Ganze bei maximal 4 Grad. Die Straßen sind frei, wir wünschen euch eine gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn ihr schon immer mal wissen wolltet, wie ein Stimulator klingt, dann hört ihr das jetzt gerade. Aber auch immer sonntags. In der oberhammerkrass starken Action-Super-Show mit mir. Dem Stimulator. Ach ja, Kathrin Thüring und Jakob Lund sind da auch immer dabei.
Die Sonntagsfritzen.
Immer sonntags ab 14 Uhr auf Fritz.
Heute Chaos Radio im Blue Moon zu Gast sind vom Chaos Computer Club Erdgeist, Danny Mohn und Starbuck. Hallo und guten Abend.
Hallo.
Und wir reden heute darüber, wie der Chaos Computer Club sowas wie den Chaos Communication Congress organisiert. Das machen nämlich alles Freiwillige und wir haben so die verschiedenen Baustellen, die man braucht, um so eine zehntausend Leute Veranstaltung auf die Beine zu stellen. Man fragt sich mal, wie macht man sowas eigentlich? Das wird heute so ein bisschen genauer erklärt. Und wir haben tatsächlich euch auch aufgerufen, anzurufen, falls ihr selber auf dem Kongress wart und dazu etwas erzählen wollt. Und das ist tatsächlich passiert, nämlich der Pluto hat angerufen. Pluto ist 20, kommt aus Wien. Hallo und guten Abend.
LUTO.
Ah, das wurde mir falsch aufgeschrieben. Du warst auf dem Kongress.
Ich war auf dem Kongress und ich bin ein bisschen krankheitsmäßig umgekippt und wollte mich eigentlich mal an Zert bedanken, weil ich während dem Kongress nicht wirklich dazu gekommen bin. Ich bin wirklich extrem nett um mich gekümmert.
Also Zert, das hatten wir gerade vor den Nachrichten erklärt, das sind die Leute, die sich auf dieser großen Veranstaltung um die medizinischen Notfälle kümmern. Da hatten wir Madoc gerade am Telefon und du bist ihm quasi in die Hände gefallen.
Kann man so sagen, ja.
War das dein erster Kongress?
Nein, es war mein zweiter. Ich war am 30.3. zum ersten Mal und ja, es war dementsprechend der zweite.
Wie würdest du jemanden, der noch gar nicht auf dem Kongress war, das beschreiben?
Den Kongress allgemein? Ziemlich, also der erste war ziemlich überwältigend.
Weil, was passiert da?
Ich bin wirklich reingekommen und es ist, man kommt auf den Bahnhof. Also in Hamburg ist halt der Bahnhof dort, der Dammtor, der Bahnhof. Und man kommt wirklich rein in eine komplett andere Welt. Also es ist alles dekoriert, es sind alle extrem freundlich. Man hat überall irgendjemand, den man einfach anreden kann, der mir was braucht. Und es sind viele Menschen, die man einfach fragen kann, was sie da gerade tun und die erklären das dann einfach so.
Das heißt, man muss da keine Angst haben?
Nein, Angst gibt, also ich hätte nicht mitbekommen, dass ich Angst gehabt habe am Congress.
Sehr schön. Gut, dann wolltest du also nur deinen Dank sozusagen beim Zert nochmal abgeben? Dann sei das hiermit geschehen und vielen Dank für deinen Anruf. So, das ist wirklich harzerwärmend, diese Geschichten. Es gibt also da Netzwerke und ein eigenes Telefonnetz und medizinische Notfälle, da wird sich auch drum gekümmert. Und es wird sich auch um die Leute gekümmert, die zum aller, aller, erstmal da sind, sich nicht so richtig trauen. Und zwar von den sogenannten Chaos-Party-Nen. Und was das ist, erklärt uns jetzt Fiona. Hallo und guten Abend. So, Chaos-Party-Nen. Was sind die? Was machen die? Warum gibt es die?
Die Chaos-Party-Nen, das ist ein Programm, das es seit letztem Jahr gibt. Und, was wir schon gesagt, wir betreuen neue Leute, die zum ersten Mal auch in Konkret kommen, in den sie ihre Fragen beantworten und auf den Kongress, in dem wir ihnen Paten zuordnen, die sie willkommen heißen, auf den Kongress rumführen und für sie Ansprechpartner sind. Und witzigerweise, der Lutho, der gerade anrufen hat, war selber Chaos-Pate. Und dem auch nochmal vielen Dank, dass er einen Chaos-Party gemacht hat. Es sei denn, es war ein anderer Lutho, aber das bezweifle ich.
Das war wirklich der Lutho.
Die Chaos-Paten sind ja genau wie alle anderen Leute auch Freiwillige. Wer meldet sich denn da so? Sind das die ganz alten Hasen oder Leute, die auch erst zum dritten Mal da sind? Oder wie funktioniert das?
Von den Paten und Patinnen, also ja, es gibt so die Leute, die einfach schon seit zehn Jahren dabei sind oder länger und gerne etwas weitergeben möchten von ihrer Begeisterung. Aber erfreulicherweise hatten sie dieses Jahr zum Beispiel auch Patenkinder von letztem Jahr dabei, weil die letztes Jahr selber Patenkinder waren, bei den Chaos-Patenern zum ersten Mal und meinten, ja, sie würden gerne ihre tollen Erlebnisse und was sie so gelernt haben, weitergeben an die Leute, die dieses Jahr zum ersten Mal dabei waren, also beim Kongress.
Und wie macht ihr es dann? Teilt ihr einfach sozusagen die Zahl der Chaos-Kinder durch Paten, die zur Verfügung stehen, und dann werden die einfach mitgegeben oder wird das noch irgendwie besonders ausgelost?
Das ist auf jeden Fall Teil des Prozesses, damit man sagen kann, wie groß die Gruppen ungefähr sind. Aber es fängt eigentlich so ein bisschen vor dem Kongress an. Ein paar Wochen vorher machen wir das Publik, dass es uns wieder gibt. Und dann kann man sich bei uns anmelden mit einer E-Mail und ein bisschen was über sich erzählen. Und wir verwalten das Ganze in so einer Software. Und dann matchen wir die Paten-Kinder mit Paten und Pateninnen, die gut zu ihnen passen. Also es melden sich vielleicht vier, fünf Leute, sind voll die Fans von der Metaebene. Und wenn die sich zufällig für die gleichen Podcasts, die kommen dann wahrscheinlich in eine Gruppe zusammen, sodass sie auch gleich eine Bezugsgruppe haben und kriegen dann einen Paten zugewiesen. Denn die Idee des Ganzen ist ja, dass wir uns selber überflüssig machen und die eigentlich uns gar nicht brauchen nach ein paar Stunden oder nach einem Tag. Und am besten mit ihrer eigenen Gruppe oder selber Freunde finden. Und das ist auch eigentlich so, wie es läuft. Also Leute kommen an und sind vielleicht ein bisschen eingeschüchtert oder haben aus den verschiedensten Gründen Angst vor dem großen Hacker-Kongress. Aber man muss das dann halt emotional als Pate verpacken, dass die dann Pflegel werden innerhalb kürzester Zeit und dich nie wieder melden.
Jetzt kann ich mir aber so sagen vorstellen, dass gerade das so ein Angebot ist, was auch so ein bisschen eine Anspruchshaltung generiert. Also dass dann Leute vielleicht kommen und sagen, ja so hier bin ich, jetzt unterhalte mich bitte und zeigt mir, wie das geht. Passiert sowas auch?
Ja, also es gibt solche Leute auch. Wir hatten dieses Mal ca. 130 Patenkinder, davon waren viele spontan erst bei uns, aber versuchen halt schon zu vermeiden, dass es als der große Touristenführer wahrgenommen wird auf dem Kongress, indem wir halt sagen, hey, ihr müsst euch anmelden und etwas über euch erzählen, damit wir euch jemandem zuweiten können, der oder die für euch passt. Aber wir hatten auch total viele Leute, die auf dem Kongress unserer As Family kamen. Wir hatten auch eine As Family auf dem Kongress. Zum Beispiel meinten sie, hey, Scheiße, ich bin gerade angekommen, ich hab keine Ahnung, was es hier ist und wo ich bin. Ich hab mich jetzt schon dreimal verlaufen. Auch für solche Leute sind sie da. Erfreulicherweise hat die As Family sich auch nach einer Zeit selber getragen, weil die Tatenkinder auch selber dann solche Leute durch ein Hallo gesagt haben. Und irgendwann haben sie aufgehört zu sagen, gibst du Fiona? Sondern haben dann selber gesagt, hey, was ist los? Kann man dir helfen? Ich führ dich rum. Und dann wird auch denen Leuten geholfen. Und es kommen auch Leute mit ganz verschiedenen Bedürfnissen zu uns hin.
Und das werdet ihr das nächste Jahr wieder machen, dann irgendwie noch in Größe, bis der ganze Kongress voller Paten- und Patenkinder ist? Oder wie wird das in Zukunft laufen?
Das ist nicht das Ziel. Also ich kann mir gut vorstellen, dass dieses Mal noch mehr Patenkinder von einem netten Kongress mitmachen werden. Sie brauchen wahrscheinlich auch noch ein bisschen Unterstützung im Order-Team, damit die Arbeit ein bisschen besser verteilt wird. Aber ich glaube, die Chaos-Paten haben so verschiedene Effekte. Und ich glaube, einer davon ist, dass wir diese Lücke zwischen dem, was Leute erwarten und was sie tatsächlich erwartet, ein bisschen schließen können. Denn wir uns schreien ja echt so über 100 Leute mit ihren Ängsten und warum sie jetzt die Chaos-Paten kontaktieren und warum sie jemanden brauchen. Und es ist schon eine der schönsten, aber auch erstaunlichsten Erkenntnisse sicherlich, dass es einen Riesenunterschied gibt zwischen dem, was Leute befürchten und was sie dann wirklich auf den Kongress erleben. Na die sagen halt, naja, ich bin vielleicht eine junge Frau, ich bin gar keine richtige Hackerin oder ich kenne auch niemanden, sind bestimmt alle unfreundlich, hat dann aber innerhalb kürzester Zeit viele tolle neue Freunde gefunden und ganz viel gelernt. Und man merkt halt so, dass der Beruf des Kongresses ihm vielleicht ein bisschen hinterherhängt oder dem, was einen tatsächlich erwartet. Und wir versuchen da halt zu kommunizieren, es ist überhaupt nicht so schlimm, habt Mut, sprecht Leute an und vielleicht kann man ja in zwei, drei Jahren auf die Chaos-Partynen verzichten, weil die Leute ihre Ängste verlieren, die sicherlich zum großen Teil auch durch mediale Redner-Situationen vielleicht kommen.
An dem Ruf arbeiten wir mit dieser Sendung ja auch.
Genau, wir arbeiten dran.
Also ich kann die Chaos-Partyn nur empfehlen. Nee, warte, egal. Fiona, vielen Dank und viel Glück und Spaß noch weiterhin mit den Chaos-Partynen.
Ja, danke.
Sendung fast vorbei, der Kongress ist schon mitten im Schwange. Das könnte man so sagen. Dann wurde ja immer wieder von den sogenannten Assemblies geredet. Es gibt ja vom Kongress Vorträge, die gehalten werden. Und dann gibt es dieses riesige Kongresszentrum, das ist auch irgendwie ausgeschmückt. Dann gibt es auch eine Bar und so was. Und dann gibt es halt noch die Assemblies. Was das ist, wie man die organisiert. Und was da passiert ist, wird jetzt Martin erklären. Hallo und guten Abend. Ja, das ist... Ja, ist natürlich die Frage, was macht man in solchen Fällen, vom Kongress, wenn unvorhergesehene Dinge passiert? Ist euch da schon mal was untergekommen?
Nee, immer alles super durchgeplant.
Das lügst du doch.
Und das Tolle ist, wir haben ja ganz tolle Saalengel und Saalkoordinatoren, die stellen sich dann da hin und machen erstmal ein bisschen Unterhaltung. Also langweilig.
Die Heralde. Die Heralde, Entschuldigung. Es gibt einen coolen Vortrag, ich weiß nicht mehr genau, worum es ging. Auf jeden Fall hat der irgendwie auch so einen Linux und hat mit dem Beamer nicht klarkommen. Da springt der Herald auf die Bühne und macht halt erstmal die Show. Also wenn du halt als Speaker vorne bist und deine Folien nicht funktionieren, dann bist du halt total aufgeschmissen. Das heißt, du versuchst im ersten Moment irgendwie noch das Publikum zu unterhalten, dabei so die Sachen zu fixen, was halt nicht geht. Und da ist dann halt irgendwie so der Herald irgendwie reinkommen, hat irgendwie so die Angst rausgenommen oder die Spannung rausgenommen, hat irgendwie sich mit dem Publikum unterhalten, so ein bisschen lustig erzählt und irgendwie in der Zwischenzeit konnte der Speaker dann halt irgendwie in Ruhe seine Folien irgendwie fixen.
Ja, weiter.
Er hat also quasi innerhalb dieser ganzen Zeit irgendwie eine Story erzählt, wie er irgendwie einen Gegenstand von New York über Österreich nach Berlin geschafft hat, hat das quasi in drei Kapitel unterteilt und das wäre quasi alle Talks, wo er Herald war und irgendwelche Probleme gefixt werden mussten, hintereinander hört, was man übrigens auch auf MediaCCC.de nachgucken kann. Dann kann man diese Geschichte zusammenkriegen.
Wir versuchen es nochmal mit Martin. Martin, bist du da? Wir wollten auch ganz kurz von dir wissen, was Assemblies sind und was man da so erleben kann.
Ja, also der Starbucks hatte das ja schon erwähnt, dass man das Konzept von den Villages, also dass sich die ganzen Gruppen, die irgendwie zu dem Funk-Gast fahren, sich so ein bisschen organisieren und dann Platz kriegen, wo sie sich dann auch so ein bisschen breit machen können. Es gibt ja dann auch irgendwie einen Haufen Leute, die dann recht viel Technik dabei haben. Das geht dann irgendwie über 3D-Drucker bis Splashy-Maschinen bis Löt-Equipment und so weiter.
Textilsticker, eine TARDIS.
Und was ist da deine Aufgabe gewesen?
Es sind inzwischen relativ viele Gruppen. Wir hatten über 200, die sich registriert haben. Vorher haben sie gesagt, wir würden gern kommen. Wir haben irgendwie einen Haufen Equipment dabei. Viele von ihnen hatten dann auch irgendwelche Spezialeinforderungen, dass sie gesagt haben, wir brauchen ein bisschen Strom, so 32 Ampere. Stahlstrom an unserem Platz wäre irgendwie cool. Wir brauchen schnelles Internet, also nicht so ein Gigabyte, sondern irgendwie so 10 Gigabyte. Das ist dann eher schon so Standard. Aber dann gibt es dann meistens auch noch welche mit irgendwelchen Spezialeinforderungen. Das Ganze irgendwie zu managen und gucken, dass die Leute das kriegen, was sie brauchen. Und die Leute sinnvoll im Gebäude verteilen. Das ist für die Aufgabe von dem Assembly-Team, wo ich dabei war.
Also es gibt ja erstmal die Wiki-Seite, wo sich die Assemblies eintragen, wo halt steht, wie viele Leute sie mitbringen, wie viel Platz sie brauchen, was für Besonderheiten es gibt. Und dann gibt es ja praktisch so eine Außer- bzw. eine Zusammengruppierung. Erzähl doch mal, wie dieser Prozess läuft.
Also genau, die tragen sich im Wiki ein. Da schreiben sie dann auch so ein bisschen, was sie machen, was sie vorhaben, was sie mitbringen. Und dann haben wir probiert, vor allem nachdem es jetzt zwischen so viele sind, die so ein bisschen zu gruppieren. Beziehungsweise mal nachzufragen, wenn wir uns unklar haben, was wir dabei haben, wo wir sie ein bisschen einfertieren können. Dann haben wir so 15, 20 Cluster gebildet und probiert, die halt zusammensetzen, sodass die ganzen Leute, die mit 3D-Druckern basteln, an einer Ecke sitzen, die ganzen Leute, die Software entwickeln, die Leute, die Politik machen, in einer Ecke. Dass da auch ein Austausch zwischen den ganzen Gruppen noch ein bisschen mehr gefördert wird.
Das ist ja ein viel komplexeres System. Das ist ja ähnlich, wie wenn du einen Stundenplan machen musst. Es gibt Leute, die gern ruhig sitzen und hell. Dann gibt es Leute, die gern dunkel sitzen, aber ruhig Musik vertragen. Dann gibt es Gruppen, die mit anderen Gruppen zusammensitzen, aber auf keinen Fall mit der Gruppe zusammensitzen wollen.
Das ist wie eine Hochzeitsgesellschaft, die mal aussteigen muss. Aber Tante Frieda darf nicht gegen Onkel Erna sitzen, sonst bewerfen die sich wieder.
Genau so ist das wirklich.
Es gab schon Vorschläge von denen, wo ihr gesagt habt, nein, mit radioaktiven Stoffen rumzuspielen ist nicht so eine coole Idee.
Ja, es gibt immer noch ein paar Spezialisten, die dabei sind. Die Food Hanging Base möchte natürlich dann auch ein bisschen kochen. Wenn man das konkret drum anguckt, dann ist es auf der einen Seite ein paar Kette, auf der anderen Seite ist es Teppich. Das ist beides nicht das, was man als Boden haben will, wenn Leute kochen und mit Wasser und Töpfen arbeiten.
Und überall sind wahrscheinlich Rauchmelder?
Genau, die Rauchmelder haben wir auch nicht vergessen. Die haben auch was dagegen, wenn da zu viel Zeug in der Luft ist. Oder Gruppen, die dann kommen und sagen, wir haben irgendwie so ein 3D-Troger dabei, so 1, 50 x 1, 50 Meter, für den brauchen wir dann auch irgendwie Platz.
Was ich gehört habe von den, wenn ich so Leute aus meinem Freundeskreis gemacht habe, die beliebtesten Dinge, die da ausgerührt wurden, waren der Cocktail-Bot und die Coffee Nerds. Was war deine Lieblings-Assembly?
Die Frage ist, wer hat am wenigsten Stress gemacht?
Noch an dich als letzter auch noch die Frage, warum macht man sowas? Beim Third haben wir gelernt, das ist nicht dieses, wir spielen mit Technik rum, das ist cool, sondern es ist tatsächlich, in einem Umfeld zu arbeiten, was man sonst auch macht, aber ganz anders, viel entspannter, viel relaxter. Warum gibt man sich den Orga-Stress, um sozusagen ganz viele wildgewordene Hühner unter einen Hut zu bekommen?
Na, die ganzen wildgewordenen Hühner sind dann meistens auch relativ interessant, weil sie halt irgendwelche Themen in Spezialgebieten im Land echt viele Leute kennen. Ja, das ist halt so ein großer Kommunikations-Task. Das ist eigentlich auch mal ganz nett.
Also Martin macht ja nicht nur die Assembly-Platzierung, sondern ist irgendwie auch so derjenige, der im Haus so für die Tische und Stühle fand. Also wenn du halt so gesagt hast, da unten steht zu viel Tische oder irgendwie, wir brauchen auch Tische, dann gehst du halt auch zu Martin.
Wie lange brauchst du, um dich davon zu erholen nach dem Kongress? Alles klar, Martin organisiert die Assemblies, sind doch so kleine extra Sachen, wo Leute Dinge tun. Martin, vielen Dank und viel Spaß auch weiterhin. So, jetzt haben wir uns fast zwei Stunden damit beschäftigt, wie man eigentlich so einen Chaos Communication Congress organisiert. Was ich jetzt so als Bottomline mitnehme, ist so, okay, ihr macht das zwar alles selber und es ist unbezahlt und man könnte es theoretisch auch irgendwie aus dem Boden stampfen, aber da ist schon was herangewachsen über die Jahre, was man jetzt mal nicht so einfach nachmacht, würde ich mal vermuten.
Also, nicht in der Größe.
Es gibt viele Teams, die einfach auch unabhängig den Kram machen, das POG-Team zum Beispiel hat eine kleine Firma auch ausgegründet und macht jetzt auch andere Großveranstaltungen, Decktelefone, das heißt, wenn man ähnliche Sendungsbewusstsein hat und so eine Veranstaltung wuppen möchte, dann kann man auch auf viel von den Teams und viel von der Software zugreifen, die wir da schon noch oben liegen haben. Wahrscheinlich in genau der Größenordnung wird man es nicht hinbekommen, aber so viele Besucher muss man erstmal aktivieren.
Ja, aber würdet ihr tatsächlich sagen, weil der Gedanke vom Chaos Computer Club ist ja immer irgendwo auch machen, also dieses Sagen, ich möchte mich jetzt hinsetzen und nicht für 10.000, aber keine Ahnung, für 100 oder vielleicht auch nur für 50 Leute so was auf die Beine stellen.
Das muss man eine Angst vorhaben? Ich würde schon sagen ja, weil diese Nerd-Kultur ist halt was Besonderes. Also ein gutes Beispiel dafür, wie dieses wir brauchen Hilfe und Leute machen mit, war irgendwie bei mir am dritten Tag. Wir haben irgendwie die total unsinnige Idee gehabt, die Garderobe von einem Ende des Hauses zum anderen Ende des Hauses zu verlegen.
Warum?
Mitten in der Nacht, also um 5 Uhr nachts. Ich bin halt einfach zu Leuten, die dort noch gehackt haben, hab gesagt, Jungs, wir haben jetzt hier eine Stunde Scheißaufgaben, habt ihr Bock mitzuhelfen? Es sind alle aufgestanden. Wir waren dann zum Schluss mit 20, 30 Leuten, die Koffer durch die Gegend gefahren haben. Und das ist halt wirklich das Coole. Nicht nur in der Organisationsstruktur finden sich Leute, die mitmachen und die selber Sachen organisieren, sondern du kannst auch einfach zu random people hingehen und sagen, wir brauchen Hilfe. Und sie sind einfach in der Regel sofort mit dabei und helfen dir, wo es geht.
Ich sag dir, wenn du es vorlebst, folgen die Leute.
Okay, zwei Stunden Chaosradio, zwei Stunden über eine Gohaka-Großveranstaltung, wie man sie organisiert. Falls ihr jetzt nicht selber eine machen wollt, wollt ihr vielleicht...
Aber wir wollen selber eine machen. Im Sommer. Wir müssen noch das Camp ankündigen. Dieses Jahr, genauso wie vor vier Jahren, vor acht Jahren, vor zwölf Jahren und vor 16 Jahren, gibt es dieses Jahr wieder das Chaos Communication Camp. Und zwar vom...
13. bis 17.
August. Na, nicht mehr ganz so in der Nähe von Berlin. Also wir sind jetzt ein bisschen weiter nach Norden gegangen.
Zwischen zwei Autobahnen. Also ziemlich genau zwischen zwei Autobahnen an der Grenze zu Mecklenburg-Vorpommern.
Ist in einer alten Ziegelei. Und die Umgebung ist sehr schön. Also anders als die letzten Jahre, wo wir immer so ein bisschen auf dem Flughafen waren, wo das Wasser gefiltert ist, gibt es diesmal Wasser und Idylle. Und es verspricht auf jeden Fall eine sehr schöne Veranstaltung zu werden. Also wer noch nicht auf dem Camp war oder noch nicht auf dem Kongress war, sollte das auf jeden Fall ins Auge fassen, das zu tun. Und selbst wer schon da war, also wer da war, wird auf jeden Fall hinkommen.
Da kann man mit Familie, da kann man mit ohne Familie einfach Zelt schnappen, hinwerfen. Gibt wahrscheinlich Internet, gibt Strom, gibt sogar Hygiene inzwischen.
Verrückt, das teilt weniger zu tun.
Da gibt es halt drei Sien, die noch funktionieren.
Also das ist halt wirklich irgendwie der Congress nochmal potenziert. Also nicht von der Anzahl der Leute, aber vom Coolheitsfaktor. Also weil du halt einfach auf dem Acker, also es wird halt dort auch Netzwerk geben, es gibt dort auch WLAN, es gibt halt die ganzen Gruppen, die wir jetzt aufgezählt haben, gibt es dort auch wieder, aber in einer viel extremeren Art und Weise, weil du halt einfach die Sachen auf dem Acker machen musst.
Okay, also eine Hacker Großteilanschaltung auf dem Acker, ich bin gespannt. Erdgeist, Danimo und Starbuck, vielen Dank fürs hier sein und mal erklären, wie das alles so geht. Ihr könnt diese Sendung, wenn ihr noch nicht alles mitbekommen habt, noch als Podcast hören, erscheint im Laufe der Nacht auf fritz.de, später dann irgendwann auch auf chaosradio.ccc.de. Wenn ihr Fragen habt, stellt sie gerne, könnt eine Mail schreiben an chaosradio.ccc.de, es gibt auch einen Twitter-Account, ihr seid also versorgt. Vielen Dank euch fürs Zuhören und auch für die Geschichten, die uns teilweise hier erzählt habt. Ich sage nur noch eine Sache, mein Name ist Marcus Richter. Lasst uns nicht überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups.